I do want to remind you that we have
this reddit discussion forum and the
discussion there lately has been really
really good i'm gonna show you some of
the topics that have been coming up on
our reddit discussion forum you can of
course access it by going to david
pakman.com slash reddit that's our ed di
t you can propose guests there you can
propose stories viewers talk to each
other let's look at just a couple of the
recent stories that have popped up on
our reddit discussion forum the first
one which i will show you why is david
not covering the Podesta email leaks I
like David I don't align with this
political ideology but he's usually a
fair honest journalist who covers a lot
of important issues maybe there's a
legitimate reason like too much info to
sift through this quickly but I'm
curious why he hasn't at least attempted
to cover the Podesta email leaks well
fortunately because I participate in
that forum on a mostly daily basis I was
able to go in and say we've covered the
Podesta leaks multiple times and uh that
is just uh maybe you just didn't see it
so a lot of people interested in the
Podesta leaks another interesting
question brought up on our reddit
discussion forum are we seeing the
biggest shift in liberal conservative
core values ever this election cycle and
this is an interesting post from bell
rocks pointing out a lot of the ways in
which we've seen ideologies and
candidates slightly or at least as bell
rocks is arguing significantly realigned
during this election very interesting
discussion there and we've been talking
about that on the program somebody else
mentioning on our reddit discussions
forum simulation theory what does
everyone think of these theories the
idea that we might be living in a
computer simulation I love that topic
and I've actually interviewed astro
physicist Lawrence Krauss about it and
lastly an interesting comment from
boosie 772 on a reddit discussion forum
hopefully Paul Ryan knows what he's
doing referencing the idea that uh Paul
Ryan maybe could get Trump to not win
but maintain control of the House and
Senate in a way that Republicans could
completely and totally obstruct Hillary
Clinton
something I do want to talk about more
later on so join us on our reddit
discussion forum david pakman.com slash
reddit that'll redirect you subscribe
participate I'm there almost daily I
know Pat is checking it out as well so
check it out a lot of stories to talk
about